- Que ce soit Elon Musk,
Jeff Bezos ou Bernard Arnault,
les dix hommes les plus fortunés
de la planète s'en sont mis
plein les poches depuis le début
de la pandémie.
Selon un rapport de l'ONG Oxfam,
leurs avoirs sont passés de
700 à 1500 milliards de dollars.
DENISE BYRNES,
DG, Oxfam Québec
- Ceux qui sont en haut de la
pyramide, le petit groupe de
gens très privilégiés,
ont doublé leur fortune,
les dix hommes les plus riches,
pendant que la majorité des gens
sur la planète ont vu
voir d'achat,
leurs revenus baisser.
- Ne pouvant profiter de juteux
gains en bourse comme les hyper-
riches, 160 millions dens dens e
personnes ont basculé dans
la pauvreté depuis mars 2020
à l'échelle planétaire.
La pandémie a causé des pertes
d'emplois et forcé certains,
mais surtout certaines,
à rester à la maison.
- Beaucoup de femmes ont dû
arrêter leur travail ou leur
façon de gagner leur vie pouur r
s'occuper de personnes malades,
s'occuper d'enfants à la maison,
etc.
- Au Canada,
les 59 milliardaires du pays
ont vu leur fortune globale
grimper de plus de moitié.
Mais l'écart entre le revenu
disponible des 10 % de la
population les plus fortunés et
celui des 10 % les plus pauvres
s'est rétréci. Il est passé
de 46 à 43 % depuis le début
de la pandémie.
en fait, on est au plus
petit écart jamais enregistré
depuis 1999, si je me trompe
pas.
- C'est l'effet des mesures de
soutien du gouvernement et de la
redistribution de la richesse.
CATHERINE HAECK, p,
sciences économiques, UQAM
- Les mécanismes de
redistribution via les impôts
et les transferts
de mitiger ces écarts-là
et de revenir à des écarts qui
sont assez stables, somme toute,
à travers le temps. Évidemment,
c'est pas une situation idéale,
là, on aimerait mieux
que les gens puissent avoir des
revenus de travail plus égaux.
vernement a aidé
les gens durant la COVID aussi,
ce qui est très bien, mais reste
qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui
font un peu du surplace en
termes de pouvoir d'achat. Par
exemple, on sait qu'il y a une
inflation importante, mais les
gens qui sont au salaire minimum
ne suivent pas la courbe.
- Pour récupérer une partie
de l'argent qu'engrangent
les hyper-riches, Oxfam réclame
la mise en place d'impôts
sur la fortune et le capital.
Mais pour que certains payent
leur juste part, il faudra
lutter contre les échappatoires
et les paradis fiscaux.
Ici Olivier Bachand,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.